shut up
would you stop with the nonsense hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
he's the president's son
and short of physically harming somebody
else he's not going to jail
and oh by the way the Republicans in the
house want to be in an uproar they want
to be apoplectic because my God prefer
retro treatment was accorded to the son
of the president of the United States of
America
why the hell would it preferate your
treatment be accorded to the son of the
president of the United States
if I'm the command-in-chief
I'm in charge of law enforcement
throughout the country the head of the
justice department is appointed by me
state attorney generals and Beyond
answer to the justice department or the
State Attorney General's
why wouldn't I have an inside track why
wouldn't I have enrolls I'm not saying
it's right I'm saying why are we walking
around acting like we had gassed over
this shut up
we just stop with the nonsense
oh my God money shouldn't matter but it
does contact I mean contacts shouldn't
matter but it does
nothing's gonna happen to Hunter Biden
and oh by the way Hunter Biden who was
doing crack
is not the president his daddy is
and his daddy who said that he said one
behind closed door some secret tape
revealed by TMZ or something
Vice President Biden told that to the
media
and now years later we want to use that
as an excuse to impeach him
just because everybody went out to Trump
with the Pawns
we're the ones not getting things done
for us I'm talking white black and
everybody in between under the
stewardship of our government on Capitol
Hill who seems to do a far greater job
of servicing themselves than servicing
all of us as the American people that is
the crime
what we really need to do as American
citizens
is say to one another
despite our differences let's come
together and demand that they stop
wasting our money on Petty bull
and that they go about the business of
getting the work done on Capitol Hill
that's what we really really really
should be coming together